[Music]
joana here your iCloud storage is full
if you want your photos to remain safe
you have to pay me now if you don't pay
the incessant pop ups will continue in
your precious memories will be in severe
danger your threats and pop-ups don't
scare me iCloud
okay maybe this is a touch dramatic but
those soul-crushing
out of storage iCloud notifications
could mean you're losing precious data
and photos but we've got this under
control
there are three ways to defuse the
hostage situation
option one delete backups to clear
iCloud space defeating iCloud at its own
game Apple gives everyone five gigs of
free iCloud space that's an insanely
small amount for anyone and even more
insane when you realize that iCloud
backups count towards it so go to
settings tap your name at the top iCloud
and then manage storage and tap the
backup line now delete backups of
devices you don't use do not delete the
one that says this iPhone you can always
turn off iCloud backups entirely but
remember your phone won't be backing up
okay you next time option to use a
different cloud photo service if you
don't want to pay Apple I recommend
Google photos it offers unlimited photo
back up though photos over 16 megapixels
will be downsized making the transition
takes a few steps first on your phone in
iCloud settings turn off iCloud photo
library then on your computer Mac or PC
export all the photos you have an iCloud
go to google photos and upload them then
back on your iPhone download the Google
Photos app and set it up there to
automatically backup shots not Google
photos
option three give in and pay the iCloud
ransom yes you can give in to the
threats and pay Apple one dollar a month
for fifty gigabytes three dollars for
200 gigabytes or ten dollars for two
terabytes there are some other pluses to
paying Apple now lets you share storage
with the whole family and you'll have
enough storage that you can backup stuff
from your computer of course if you've
gone this route it feels like iCloud is
one I got your money
I got your money I'll get you next time
iCloud
[Music]